I once went out to the bar and then I
was a drinking and then I drank a more
bar because it was a stinking oh yeah
it's a pub sorry we got it wrong it's a
yeah we a pub with our rolly bins it's a
br rolly bins and our B and we keep
drinking till we end up in the rly bins
and then we keep drinking some more okay
just going to correct you it was wheelie
bins but it's okay you guys were doing
bins
come his face ah I'm going to get you
wow you miss get your knife you br oh
[__] don't do it again you'll never get
me what you
doing I'm GNA long range you ready oh
God damn it Miss me come get it close
yeah I shot you in the arm what the hell
I even saw the blood never get me bring
it on Bob you this is like watching a
[__] fight oh no you get stuck in here
okay oh come
on hor Jack I've gotten some good shots
oh come on that was right on you don't
even try I can you were a mile away from
me you like miles away from me I I
totally forgot I can Sprint and then uh
turns out that I've lost all faith in
Mark what I've never had much faith in
me either de eyes don't
work all right hey everyone
here hi how you doing how you doing so
who's the murderer then I don't know
who's
Whois I don't have anything I'm the
cashier hello welcome
to oh oh God cashier look out he got a
gun Charlie don't move my my virtual
hands are in the air I can't do it put
your hands up I can put my face up like
put your face up put it up put it put it
up sorry chill out can I leave Bob Bob
can I leave no please whiskey you can
leave why whiskey
leave
uhoh you shouldn't let me leave B I
always get let me leave I have an idea I
have an idea who has the gun I do not so
whoever has the gun get the gun out yeah
do that listen to him because he's
definitely not the murderer you should
um Sierra Sierra I am I am Delta come
here well follow me follow me don't do
it everyone everyone but Sierra come in
here okay and we'll have a little target
practice everyone what Sierra get over
there okay well Sierra has to do the
shooting so everyone everyone other than
Sierra get over here
okay where
you no oh
God okay okay wait wait wait wait come
back come back okay it's either me or
Oscar I'm November who's it going to be
who do you trust more I mean come
on do never trust never
trust this is an old moment Bob you got
to go for it uh who's com who's coming
to your Bor party
tomorrow right I should kill you uh
oh
uh wait get
him oh I'm sorry Wade Wade I left you
for
last
Rush why cuz you're the murderer Wade
there's no way we're gonna listen to you
I'm not the murderer cuz I've got the
gun own you have the gun on his own Echo
hey everyone I have an
idea what Bob's murderer never mind H
murder I'm dead so no I'm
not oh no wait I was the murderer last
time I'm not going to be the murderer
two times in a row I you hello Sierra
are you zombie mold are you the silent
can't see more like deagon hey come in
here hey everyone yeah I am Juliet I'm
green come here where okay over here a
murderer I'm in it I don't I believe you
I trust you this is a machine that will
test if you are a traiter or oh cool do
I jump in here yeah hop in okay cool I'm
going for
it turned out green is that mean he's
good Mark was not a Traer okay cool yeah
I'm not the Traer so I'll go next okay
who has okay who this is what weird what
where am I now I got I got poured into
some strange I can't see anything what
the heck hello Mark you turned into a
melon no I didn't what huh what Mark
you're a watermelon where am I am iide
the watermelon watermelon you got to
crack it open okay with what I don't
whoever's got the gun crack all you miss
good
job you goddamn idiots I'm dead kill him
you killed my friend you to crack it
open jeez talk about cold blooded wow oh
okay wait you saw
nothing I saw
something man saw a little something
something godam
it there you go hat your face idot okay
I have a gun and I say everybody STI up
stop pushing the door stop it it's the
three stes all over again who's doing
this who's doing this really God who's
doing this I'm I'm going to kill one of
you for doing this okay bye oh I'm dead
oh God oh my God no who did it who did
it who did it why can't I see inside
that
room a graphical bug inside that room
hi he'll never get us in this together
spread out you [__] we'll be saving
this carard he can't see us you idiots
the gun was in in there we were
camouflaged I don't know how he saw us
must have been a fluke where yeah there
was a graphical glitch yeah ex green on
green you guys are idiots oh
God thanks Bob thanks for the support
and all your love I like killing you
guys thank you thank I like murder it's
like I can finally take out my
aggression for all the mean things you
do next time next time you're the murder
Wade murder us as goofy okay actually
that applies to anyone anyone who's the
murder murder as goofy you can be
yourself until you start murdering then
you have to be goofy no no no you can be
you have to be
goofy okay that's a little weird no no
no no listen to me hey how you want to
know how I got so many
subscribers listen to me pleas I'm
listening intently what the hell let's
crack the melons off each other hey pick
up your melon um guys found I found Mr
derpa Dine what I'm not joking it
literally says oh God where is this at
oh God it's just a toilet in
here where are What where are you walls
I'm getting out of here oh thank
you you don't want to see where is this
happening no no no on the
playground what there's a dungeon in a
playground where a
playground oh is
that oh what a lucky gu I mean oh what a
lucky guess oh gor oh God what's going
on what happened oh God B I think yeah
some hey guys guess where the gun is no
I went down I got messed
up yeah no here here here here I'm
putting my knife away hey everyone come
back outside come back outside come here
I'm going to the dungeon you have to
come out here to get the
gun see look this got the right idea
yeah who where what why I assume it's
zombie where zombie run
zombie your face oh not this again this
again wor not this God thank God Mark is
horrible shut your mouth I am going to
blow your brains out he you just pop
your head up be careful you're just
blowing ass right now oh God the worst
do it just
missing I got to get to the dungeon
hey wait what hey hey
waade what get him get him Wade get him
waade that was the worst Miss than I
ever did get him Ro get him Rock You got
to clean his out you got to clean him
out
to way to go Wade save that that was
horrible I swear there's some lag on
that gun I had you dead center a million
times a million times milon have trouble
shooting someone in the dark abyss from
that's cuz I guided him I gave him
advice Bob Bob you're my new best friend
you saw I gave him going to the
playground this is a pretty sweet bed
nobody can join my where are you people
come check my bed out get in the
playground wait bed are you in the
dungeon are you oh no no no oh God are
you in Theon what happened here oh what
happened who
di I got mail I going to take the mail
Inside by who no it's not safe Jack it's
not safe oh God oh God I body fly from
the
doorstep I died wasn't me 5 Seconds
before that would have been helpful oh
God I said I died and you looked at my
dead body that was outside I was heading
inside with the mail so uh oh hello all
no no you don't yeah come out that door
come out that
door going again is
it I liked how Jack came to ring the
doorbell I just opened the door and
stabbed him I was bringing you your mail
you douche that was a good strategy
though we don't like mail in America
it's always bills yeah cuz we're always
in debt by the time we're out of college
we're half our lifetime in debt that's
sad and don't you have all that YouTube
monies no where is that Promised Land I
was T told Promised Land what are you
talking about you two buies doesn't
apply to the most of us here
yeah hey Zulu you this is a nice bed oh
this is a lovely bed
zombie is that you can we all be a happy
fun family in the house if that's you
zombie stop who oh goie hey let's go is
there is there trouble in this
neighborhood there's Trouble in
Terrorist Oh wrong mode no no no no no
no you can't uniform come down my alley
nice get away
oh good job zombie
zie who did what who did what K Wade in
his stupid face I heard a gunot sure
that was bom who is that oh it was it
yeah that was me I got a gun who's got
the gun what who's shooting at
me I might have just missed you by a
hair are you a murderer Marky Mar no are
you a murder hey out here in
the I think you
are hey run the courtyard god I didn't
even try to kill you a douchebag
told me you were not I I didn't try to
kill you now did I I wasn't a murderer I
didn't kill anyone you're the one with
blood on your hands I'm the murderer PL
twist murderer oh I didn't kill nobody
if you murder a murderer doesn't that
make you a murderer no yes it does but
makes you a murderer murderer which they
cancel out KN the door again oh God Lima
is being a douche and is messing with
the door I am not messing with the door
look are you Lima it's barar Lima in the
face not
here
that scared me oh my God God that was
zombie that was horrifying I am Victor
and I am the murderer everyone has to do
what I say I don't believe you the Delta
you're not
goofy
shot Jack Jack where are you be
okay I'm November you and me we're going
to go somewhere away from them are you
going to kill me are we
going no no no one else is no what are
you doing get out of my
house close in don't open them
inows them you
open
they moment you guys are ruining
it they're being
weird
Jack Jack do you have the gun no I wish
did and now you're stuck oh you got out
no no of course not hi hi okay that's
you Bob okay you I'm running away I'm
running awayk I'm coming I'm coming I'm
coming I can still see you
guys we're not fast
enough they're like murderer
fast I closed the door oh I found a dark
tank boom I like this honey they're in
the house
honey okay are we all honey I'm home hi
hi this is my house welcome yeah you're
not welcome this be my crib this where I
sleep here yeah this where I sleep all
the cowboy boxes
nice oh my God me come here what you
doing where's it going where's it going
where's it going where's it going I
wonder where it is Si now you and I can
be a happy family together we're not we
don't have to be alone ever again no run
away Jack such a liar Jack come back I
just want to feel your skin against my
face he's standing on the gun Jack okay
how about how about we settle this like
men okay yes please he's going to throw
out to the wall
okay I will make you beautiful you will
be a great wife for
me you eat a big bag of dicks right now
oh no Jack
wow to too far waa that's
not not cool here man I don't know where
I am I'm on the roof this is awesome
there's a
lever roof a lever opens a ladder to a
secret layer where where oh wait oh my
roof god what the hell where I don't
know where I am H is happening tell some
Secrets oh God what did I I went up over
lollipop Mountain I went through gum
tree forest and I came out here I found
a hiding spot does anyone want to join
me I'm on my owning
spot last time you said that you killed
us we were a happy family they were
bothering us I took care of the
problem they were a
problem and I Sol in
so
shirt anyway I found my I found a hiding
spot if anyone else wants it I'll solve
your problem who's that in the yellow
shirt who is that I'm Delta look up here
hi I'm Papa hi Papa B you're on the roof
Papa what you doing cleaning chimneys uh
hiding for murderers can I join you
there he has a gun oh wait purple roof
guy has a gun I thought you were purple
hi purple roof guy no I'm Delta I was
the murderer before there for
statistically it is impossible that
I oh you idiots you're an [__] I
thought it was you thank you why cuz you
were talking to me good stay up there
Wade okay therefore the lesson learned
is don't talk to Wade or he will kill
you yeah both you guys on the
roof no that means oh hey you took the
gun oh I know who the I know who it is
I'm going to bed oh you're going to bed
huh oh Jack you want your family do
you that's creepy you're creepy are you
in the the
uh son of a [__] you killed him while
he was
sleeping wow right in the
ass why are you shooting I'm shooting
the targets no one kill
me oh if you actually hit the targets
you think something will happen oh ah
who killed me mar Target who killed me I
was just exploring okay I hit all the
targets nothing happened that was a
waste of time good job I'm dead the
culmination of your abilities is I'm
dead no you were like 10t away from
me I think I know somebody have a gun oh
God the G the gun is in front of the
double door entrance from the spawn
yeah and the murderer the murderer
standing right there the murder
definitely not very goofy oh that was
your one shot you're so dead right
now shot happened so dead wow now the
gun is camped forever you need to be
goofy you're not
goofy oh God he's in the room with the
music I can't go in there for royalty
reason I found that's the secret it
can't be in there oh no zombies in the
one place we can't get him
go turn off music he turned off the
music he's good now wait you sound like
you're sick right now sick
God zomie stop it turn it up zomie these
are serious issues
here you're about to die you're about to
kill our
channels by saying nothing by
singing all right zombie you can do this
all right it's out behind the gun store
oh boy no no no wow
oh oh my God that was ridiculous the gun
the gun is back there waie wait wait
wait okay okay okay okay get it get it
get it
get swe it was our problem Bob you said
get it get it get it of course of course
Way's GNA know even way could understand
that godam God here we go the doors
again stop it with the doors stop it
with the doors
stop it you're tearing this family apart
it we're supposed to be playing
Pictionary I'm just going to take my
wheelie bins could get me out a noose no
no it's just a TV how do you like my
roof
kilo oh I like it your
roofin Wheelin party hey no I'm no this
is bad I'm saying your roof is bad
therefore it's trash it's equivalent to
H
whoa okay Bon a little bit of an
overreaction there kilo I'm I'm running
away from you with the knife in the face
and away from me nice lady yeah I don't
think so wait don't shoot me whoa who's
got the gun oh jeez you are fast dude
good job oh oh
God Bob Bob Bob your [__] what the oh
my
God zomie shoot
him please shoot him
uh where is he left
left me oh he was a dumb dumb wow okay
wait oh God oh my God where' it go oh
God I ran right over it hang on wait
someone come here I'm uniform someone
watch this I need hey uh uh x-ray come
here watch
this whoa did you see
it hey how's it
going you doing that you good doing that
you good I'm just going to shoot blindly
into this truck if I kill one of you
it's your own fault wait a minute why
would you do that why would you do that
I kill
someone bu truck uhoh oh no did you see
that did you see that that was crazy he
just died out ofwhere so close I hit you
in the toe his blood just went
everywhere it was crazy it was Insanity
hi friend hi how you
doing God damn it I'm coming get out of
the truck no I don't want to get out of
the truck I want the murderer what are
you doing ah I'm
innocent I see him I got you Mark I got
you 104 buddy Mark's not the murderer
I'm not the murderer I'm uniform no I'm
protecting him good good no that's
not well that doesn't sound not dead
either I see I got you on a second Oh
Hang okay
no you morun zombie do
something oh he's getting ready he's
he's turning himself into a watermelon
for the fight yeah do
that i' like to fight some watermelons
okay cool wait do you not know how to
get in there and kill mark no don't tell
him
anything it's really easy Wade go Mark
Player Mark get
itam it can't shoot through it come on
Mark you got this
it oh God you
got I in my
hands so
close godam no idea he was in the front
of the truck all right God damn it damn
it okay so that that's the end of it for
now so yeah all right Wade wins I guess
so yes thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you Wade Jack and Bob
being wow okay murdery all right check
out their channels some of them may be
recording this too so you can see their
other perspective check out their other
stuff they got a lot of cool stuff going
on so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we will see you
in the next video bye-bye see you guys
by say say bye jeez you just like head
first dive bombed into the fan and flew
off it was
incredible oh no who killed these
people who did it me shoot him you can't
hit me you can't hit
me